hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Turkish drama Thriller film
called CC spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
[Music]
the movie revolves around a family from
rural turkey it includes a domineering
man named bakir his wife javia and their
three children Kadir saleha and Yusuf
bakir is a very demanding man and he
runs the family with an iron fist for
some reason he is unusually strict with
his eldest son khadir while more kind to
the younger one Yusuf he also has a
passion for making videos and in his
free time he likes to film things around
his farm in his camera in the first
scene bakir's friend visits his farm all
the way from Germany he is there to talk
about his nephew Camille who has
recently become an orphan after his
parents passed away the man requests the
cure to keep Camille with him saying the
boy is very good at farm work bakir
thinks for a while and agrees because he
too was an orphan once from that day
onwards he starts raising the boy along
with his kids later it is revealed that
Camille and saleha are good friends and
they are in fact dating kinky as bakir
falls asleep on the couch watching TV
saliha covertly sneaks out of the house
and meets Camille in the barn two flirts
and make love there meanwhile khadir
takes advantage of his sleeping father
by bringing out his expensive camera and
playing with it however when saliha
returns she inadvertently wakes their
father up and he catches khadir
red-handed playing with the camera
Furious he seizes the camera and beats
up the boy aggressively following this
bakira turns to his room and tries to
have coitus with javia but she turns
down his advances it is clear that she
is tired of her husband's brutal
Behavior towards their women she also
calls him out for being a cheater and in
response bakir says that he goes to
brothels because of the fact that his
own wife doesn't want to have
intercourse with him then he tells javia
to be grateful as he doesn't beat her
like most Turkish husbands do hearing
this Javier becomes upset prompting her
to break down in tears the following day
as Baker is working in the field with
Camille he asks the boy to start calling
him father the latter becomes emotional
and happily says yes meanwhile with
bakir away saliha plays loud music and
dances with Yusuf at home but this only
annoys their mom mother who angrily
shuts the music down she then reprimands
saliha for being a bad influence on her
brother and asks her to be more
thoughtful next time that night during
dinner Kadir asks his father if he will
send them to college the question is an
innocent one but it is enough to annoy
the old man who says that khadir is not
made for college he then asks his
daughter if she wants to go to college
but afraid of her father saleha replies
that she wants to stay in the village
with him meanwhile because of his
growing closeness with bakir saliha's
relationship with Camille starts to fall
apart this also has an effect on bakir's
relationship with his other children as
he starts prioritizing the new boy over
them one day khadir plays a harmless
prank on Camille by spraying him with a
water hose unfortunately this infuriates
bakir and he decides to punish his Elder
son he grabs his camera and asks Camille
to spray khadir with water in
retribution when the orphan boy
hesitates to oblige the Kia takes it
upon himself to humiliate his son by
drenching him and filming the whole
thing sick prank it'll go viral on
YouTube for sure soon Javi arrives and
immediately rushes to her son's rescue
she somehow convinces her husband to
stop the heinous act however he comes up
with yet another brutal punishment
bakira orders a soaking wet Kadir to
stand outside in the cold all evening
even Camille feels bad about the whole
incident so he lets khadir borrow his
warm coat later it starts to rain and
javia brings khadir back inside he
changes into warm clothes and watches
television with his dad after a while
the poor boy goes to bed while bakira
again falls asleep on the couch seeing
this an idea strikes javia's mind to
register her protest against bakir's
horrible treatment of their children she
lets him sleep in the cold by opening
the window and putting out the fire the
next morning bakir Falls sick and the
family finally experiences a relatively
peaceful day however two weeks pass by
but he does not recover javia suggests
calling a doctor but her stubborn
husband refuses to seek professional
help one day tired of being bedridden
all the time but here musters some
strength and Ventures out to get some
fresh air with the help of his favorite
son use however just as he walks a bit
further he starts coughing violently
before collapsing on the ground some
time later he sadly passes away
devastated that her husband died due to
her carelessness Javier relocates the
family to Ankara the movie then fast
forwards 30 years in the future khadir
saleha and Yusuf are now all grown and
they live distinctive lives of their own
khadir is now a filmmaker and he is
currently making a movie based on his
abusive childhood for this purpose he
has brought the film crew and his family
to their Old Farm javia has agreed to
play her own role in the film but when
the village brings back bad memories
from her past she becomes more and more
reluctant to act she also objects to
khadir recreating the scene from his
childhood when bakir brutally sprayed
him with a hose javia feels it is
disrespectful to bakir and she suddenly
starts parroting her late husband's
talking points calling khadir a
troublemaker while calling Yusuf the
most well-behaved child despite all this
the family with the help of saleha's
daughter Naz somehow manages to convince
her to act in a scene Javier is supposed
to feed an ailing bakir but when the
camera starts rolling she gets emotional
and breaks into tears as a result khadir
is forced to stop and he starts feeling
terrible especially when Nas tells him
that he will remember making his mother
cry when she dies later that night javia
Naz and saliha sit down to talk they
discuss use of suggestion about selling
the Pharma house but this only makes
javia upset so to cheer her up Nas takes
out khadir's behind the scene or BTS
camera and starts taking pictures of her
grandmother as they pose saleha recalls
the moment when she took bakir to the
hospital after he collapsed something
tells me there will be no happiness in
this movie the following day Camille
also arrives at the farm it turns out
one actor couldn't make it for the shoot
so Kadir roped in Camille in his place
later he catches up with saliha and by
the way they talk it is clear that the
two still have feelings for each other
the movie again flashes back to the past
where a young saleha is seen sneaking
out of the house to confront Camille for
ignoring her she tries getting close to
him to save their relationship but he
turns down her advances Camille didn't
want to sever the bond that he has
developed with his new father back in
the present khadir films Camille's scene
and after the shot the two catch up from
their conversation we get to know that
Camille never got married while khadir
is a divorcee later as Camille proceeds
to leave khadir asks him to redo the
scene the former asserts that he has to
visit the bank urgently but the Arrogant
filmmaker refuses to let him go amused
by khadir's stubbornness Camille jokes
that he will be sprayed with a hose if
he doesn't oblige he then agrees to
finish his part and khadir continues
filming however once everything is
wrapped up it is revealed that Camille's
joke hit too close to home and it makes
Kadir tear up after a few days saleha
returns back to the city with her mom
and daughter while khadir stays back to
finish his film soon the world is hit
with the coronavirus pandemic oh God and
turkey goes into a strict lockdown the
scene then fast forwards by two years
where khadir is seen going through all
his recorded footage when he comes
across the BTS video shot by Naz and
Javier he becomes emotional and starts
crying God jeez after the lockdown
restrictions are loosened up Yusuf and
his family finally arrive at The
Farmhouse there they noticed that the
lockdown has taken a serious toll on
khadir's health Yusuf asks him why he
still hasn't finished the movie but the
latter refuses to open up instead he
reveals that in the last two years he
hasn't spoken with either javia or
saliha hearing this Yusuf is
disappointed and he mentions that the
two are coming to the farm soon during
the conversation khadir eventually
breaks down and Yusuf Comforts his elder
brother he becomes sure that khadir is
hiding something and it's slowly eating
him from the inside the following day
saleha havia and Naz arrive at the farm
it's revealed that javia's condition is
worsened as she has developed
Alzheimer's
dude she barely recognizes anyone or
anything meanwhile saleha asks her
brother about the progress of his movie
and this time khadir replies however he
only says that he has not been able to
finish the movie because of several
reasons elsewhere Javier has become
paranoid and she chastises her own
mirror reflection calling it a bad girl
later Nas visits khadir in the editing
room and expresses concern over his
current state she then asks him about
the BTS footage she shot for the movie
however for some reason khadir gets
angry and lies to her that he has lost
it later that night the three siblings
contemplate selling The Farmhouse Yusuf
wants to sell the property because he
has lost his job due to the pandemic
saliha and kadira are opposed to the
idea so Yusuf makes sarcastic comments
about the alimony she receives from her
ex-husband this expectedly upsets saliha
and she calls both of her brothers out
for being so clueless about her life she
explains that she has stopped receiving
alimony from her ex and that she too is
struggling to pay her bills like
everyone else hearing this Yusuf
apologizes but then he starts making
comments about his elder brother when
the situation boils out of hand khadir
slaps him right across the face suddenly
javia arrives and finally recognizes her
children she recalls the time little
Yusuf came running to her to reveal that
bakir had collapsed on the ground a
happy memory at last the movie then cuts
to the Past after bakir collapsed the
family took him to a hospital and there
bakir gained Consciousness and told
javia that he won't make it out alive he
tells her that one day their kids will
grow up and want to sell their Farm but
javia must never let them he says he
wants his grandchildren to see the farm
their granddad built with his bare hands
after bakir passed away javya didn't
sell the property but she didn't stay
either for a new start she moved the
family to Ankara saliha protested the
decision but Javier refused to listen to
her back in the present after dinner the
family decides to have some fun really
Yusuf challenges his sister to a dance
and plays the song from their childhood
which got them in trouble with their
mother the following day Camille arrives
with bakir's newly refurbished old car
turns out that Yusuf had put it in for
refurbishment and couldn't go to pick it
up so Camille brought it home out of
courtesy he is still the kind and caring
gentleman that he used to be Camille
then reveals that khadir regularly
visits his dad's grave apparently
because he misses him this comes as a
surprise to the other siblings as khadir
and their dad had a strained
relationship later the entire family
sits for lunch where Javier recognizes
Camille and slowly walks over to him
then all of a sudden she starts
attacking him for fooling around with
saliha as a child it turns out it was
actually habia who had warned Camille
against pursuing a relationship with
Celia which led to the breakdown of
their relationship meanwhile Naz hangs
around in kidir's editing room and there
she comes across the distressing footage
of the bakir housing khadir down with
water in the next scene Camille gets
ready to leave and saliha packs him
dinner but after saying his goodbyes and
walking a distance he returns back he
then confesses to saleha that when she
was in the last year of college he had
traveled to Ankara to find her he
eventually located her but decided to
leave her alone because she seemed happy
in life without him around this makes
saliha emotional as she is once again
reminded how different her life would
have been with Camille meanwhile Naz
confronts khadir in his room and asks
him if his childhood was troubled with
tears in his eyes he says what the hell
do you think but also mentions that he
has moved on from it following this Naz
inquires if he has really lost the BTS
footage and when khadir finally comes
clean she rushes to the editing room she
eventually finds the camera hidden in a
drawer and plays it the commotion
attracts the attention of saliha and
Yusuf who also gather around the screen
in the video Javier recalls the night
before bakir fell sick she reveals that
she had slipped some sleeping pills in
bakir's tea and let him sleep in the
cold without fire and open Windows javia
says that if bakir wasn't drugged he
would have woken up and closed the
windows after watching the entire video
Naz watches in astonishment as javia
breaks into tears regretting giving the
sleeping pills to her husband the movie
ends as khadir also arrives to confirm
that javia had a role in their father's
death I'm gonna go take a cold shower
I'm gonna go take a cold shower now what
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching